after 13 years britney spears is
officially free from her conservatorship
[Music]
yes it is empowering now that the
conservatorship is over the 39 year old
pop star will have many of her freedoms
restored it's been a lot of hard work
it's been intense
i'm proud
brittany's proud ahead of the hearing
earlier this week brittany took to
instagram to share how she was feeling
leading up to this monumental day in a
now deleted caption alongside one of her
favorite pieces of artwork the singer
wrote this week is going to be very
interesting for me i haven't prayed for
something more in my life
in 2008 britney entered into a
conservatorship with her father jamie
spears after she suffered a very public
breakdown this resulted in jaime
reportedly having full control over
britney's financial and medical affairs
fast forward to 13 years later the
singer's loyal fans started the hashtag
free britney movement and a number of
documentaries chronicled the injustices
of britney's conservatorship her own
phone and her own private conversations
were used so often to control her
earlier this year in june brittany gave
an explosive testimony in court where
the singer revealed how the
conservatorship has negatively impacted
her life on september 29th britney's dad
jamie was officially suspended as the
conservator of his daughter's estate
and in drastic turn of events on
november 1st jaime requested that the
conservatorship end as soon as possible
citing in court documents that he sees
no reason for it to continue i don't
think any conservatorship attorney in
this country has seen a case like
britney's conservator attorney tamar
armanak was the conservator attorney for
amanda bynes she expressed to e.t why
this has been such an unusual case so
much is involved so much press so much
media
just the general fame and power that the
conservative came with into the
conservatorship and the fact that she's
continued to work and earn an amazing
living while on this conservatorship
it's very unusual
in britney's bombshell testimony from
june the singer said that her father
jamie should be punished for the
handling of her conservatorship
something her attorney matthew rosengart
said he plans to look into jamie spears
and others
are going to face even more serious
ramifications
for his misconduct
i said at the outset that my firm and i
were going to take
a top to bottom look at what jamie
spears
and his representatives have done here
that's already in process
and it will continue for as long as it
can possibly do that
to get justice for brittany when it
comes to what actual charges jaime could
potentially face here's what armanik
tells e.t
all of jamie's actions financial and
otherwise have had
the approval of the court so i'm not
sure how far conservatorship abuse
charges are going to go but it seems to
me
very clear to be very clear that mr
rosengard has said he's going to look at
what jaime did over the last 13 years
under a microscope
not in the way the judge looked at it
under a microscope so if there's
anything there i'm sure mr rosengard
will bring it to light
according to the new york times a second
hearing has been set for december 8th to
resolve britney's outstanding financial
matters now as far as what's next for
brittany in her personal life it's a
decision that brittany and only brittany
will make we do know that she has a
wedding to plan she and her fiance samus
gary announced their engagement in
september
the two began dating in 2016 after they
met on the set of her music video
slumber party and in 2019 sam opened up
to e.t about their special bond i love
the most about my relationship is the
fact that it's it's so normal you know
it's not anything like you said it's not
glamorous or anything she inspires me in
my work and also i can give so much to
her by going to the gym by by going to
work by having an actual balanced life
you know we can get
inspired by each other here and there
and really grow with each other